only on CBS this morning we're hearing
for the first time from the family of an
accused Russian spy
29 year old Maria butch inna had been in
jail cinema since July 15th she was
charged with conspiracy and acting as a
foreign agent now her father is sharing
his side of the story from her hometown
in Siberia Maria Poochyena was a regular
at gun show events in the US before
being charged as a Russian spy this
summer over email Valeri Putin told me
the charges against his daughter are not
true that she came to America to study
prosecutors claimed she was actually
part of a covert Russian influence
campaign gaining access to an extensive
network of US persons in positions to
influence political activities according
to the FBI her focus was on gun
lobbyists and conservative politicians
including National Rifle Association CEO
Wayne LaPierre and former Pennsylvania
senator Rick Santorum butchy know was
here on a student visa to study
international relations her father
claims that's why she reached out to
political figures not to spy on them
prosecutors say butanna infiltrated
those social circles using a romantic
relationship with Republican consultant
Paul Erickson Putin told me his family
has known Erickson since 2014 morning oh
he sent us these videos of himself
Maria's mother and grandmother wishing
Erickson a happy birthday last year
Putin says his daughters relationship
with Erickson is genuine and that fate
brought them together which anna faces
up to 15 years in prison last week she
was denied a request to be released into
house arrest in that same hearing
prosecutors backed off their earlier
claims that Poochyena traded sex for
access no date for her trial has been
set and you know I've been speaking with
her father over the past month and a
half or so and he calls her an
extraordinary girl who was raised in a
very ordinary town and ordinary family
it's a very different picture than what
the third year of her dream
something viana that the dad doesn't
know about his daughter he they are very
close and they speak on a daily basis so
as far as he's concerned he says this is
not the daughter that he knows that he's
being accused it's cute stuff all right